hi everyone welcome to biology professor
i'm going to be using a little bit of a
different format today we are going to
be talking about the metamorphosis of
xylophony's tersa
uh from caterpillar through to tersa
sphinx moth uh you can see my virtual
background here is one of these
caterpillars basically i found three of
them um all on the same afternoon out in
my garden and i decided to you know trap
them and put them in a terrarium and
experience their metamorphosis i took
lots of pictures and videos and i'm
gonna share it with you so this will
teach you about the uh
the the metamorphosis the life cycle of
the xylophones tersa tursa sphinx ma
and also you know if you find one of
these uh these hornworms right here in
your garden then you'll know what to do
if you'd like to
see them
go through that metamorphosis process as
well
so
i am going to share my screen
and
present this right here
oh whoops i just realized something i
should um
share my screen in a way that
means you can hear some of the videos
that i'm going to play so i'm going to
try this again share screen i'm going to
share sound and there that should be
better
so
teresa stinks moth meta metamorphosis
that's the scientific names i lost and
he's tersa and all of the pictures and
videos are by me so basically july 14th
i am in arkansas
i found three of these guys here's a
picture of one
and they were just basically crawling
around in a garden bed
i put them in a terrarium and by
terrarium i mean that i took
uh
an oxo container
and took the lid off i put soil inside
and also some of the weeds that i had
found in the area that they had been
feeding on
and then put like some cellophane over
the top and poke some holes in it so
here you can see two more of these
hornworms feeding on the weeds
eventually
actually very quickly by july 17th just
three days afterwards
they had already formed pupae here's
some early pupae
here are some later pupae a couple of
days later and then a couple of weeks
after that i had adult tersa sphinx
moths that i eventually released so
let's look at what that looks like
uh here's one of these hornworms again
the caterpillar is known as hornworms
why because they've got this uh horn on
the end um i use my i naturalist app to
identify this as a xylophone's tursa
moth
or caterpillar it would become a moth
here we have my homemade terrarium again
it was just an oxo container
i originally tried to give them hosta
leaves because the first one i had found
in my
garden bed where i was growing hostas
but they wouldn't eat any of those and
actually i found that they were eating
this other plant this other weed instead
so i had to replace that weed in the
terrarium
about twice a day they really would eat
every single leaf
and the stems would just be in here with
no more leaves on leaves on them so i
would have to replace them
so what was i feeding them actually it's
button weed so i would just find button
weed out in my yard here's what it looks
like it does have some of these little
white flowers
and they would just chew to chew this
stuff up so this is buttonweed dyodia
virginiana
according to the i naturalist app
i'm going to play a video here so you
can see them eating in the terrarium
okay
so this right here is the sphinx moth
caterpillar
that claire has named bowie
we found bowie first
uh he or she has been in our little
homemade terrarium for a couple of hours
and has been eating tons
of these these long thin leaves kind of
slowed down there a little bit
and then
we found two more
um
one is
zoe
and the other is chloe they were named
zoe in unicorn fairy but claire didn't
like that so now we've got bowie
chloe zoe
um
and they are all this kind of moth that
the spots are actually supposed to look
like snake eyes so it kind of makes them
look like like the head of a snake
when they're in the dirt
um
this one is i guess
just starting to maybe want to eat
they were kind of stunned when we picked
them up and dropped them in
this was the most recent edition and
it's still i think uh
wanting to play dead mainly
but
bowie's been here the longest and has
just been
eating eating eating
[Music]
okay so we're gonna look at them a
little bit more that video was when we
had just put them in the terrarium and
been kind of moving around a lot and
they weren't really
eating the way they they were at other
times so here's another video of them in
the terrarium
and so here you can actually see them
eating
you know they've been moving around two
of them in particular we're just eating
eating eating that last one that we
dropped in you can still kind of see it
at the bottom to be honest it never
really ate any of the button weed i
didn't seem to be interested in eating
and we'll see more about that lately i
love this view right here
you can see this guy
almost eating like a typewriter down
there just left to right up and down
eat
this one is is not really eating it's
actually kind of um
we'll see another view of that here in a
second
but it uh it never really was acting the
way the other ones were
now here we have
uh some younger pupae each of these
pictures was taken within like 24 hours
when they started to pupate so you can
still see that there's still kind of
some greenish color in there underneath
the brown and black
and then this is a couple of days later
and they have finished pupating
and have these cocoons that are actually
really beautiful i think i love the
intricacy of those cocoons
and of course even as pupae they were
moving so this video is going to show
that like when they were disturbed
sometimes you'll see them kind of twitch
so even though they are encased in their
cocoons they're definitely still alive
and able to give some some basic
responses to their environment if they
were picked up or moved for example
so there you can see it twitching and
this is just that i had i had moved the
terrarium um they actually had mostly
kind of buried themselves in the soil
but i had brushed away that top layer of
soil and so you can kind of see them
reacting to that
and then
we had
the adults emerge now this is actually
the first one the first one
which was the the caterpillar that had
not been eating at all in the terrarium
um it was the one that emerged first you
see it actually kind of on top of this
is after all three had emerged and there
are some empty cocoons here and it's
kind of on top of that
here you see a nice indicator of what
its wings look like it kind of reminds
me of like a stealth bomber or something
and so here we have some pictures of the
um
a video of the stinks moths as adults
this is before we had released them back
into the wild i had been worried that
they might need some kind of source of
hydration since they weren't able to
get to like dew on plants when they
emerged so i had put a wet paper towel
and a little cup of water in there but
to be honest they never they never paid
attention to either one they they really
just wanted to be released and this
didn't seem to give them any extra
hydration
but this you can see those wings
vibrating they kind of flicked them they
would they would fly around
note that two of them are flying up here
and one
is down here kind of in the corner
uh what i was able to see once all three
were out is that
the first
moth that emerged as an adult
it was the same
uh one that had pupated first and that
had never eaten anything and been acting
kind of abnormal
as a caterpillar and it actually when it
emerged it had defective
wings
and so let me show you what that looks
like i had two the two that had eaten
the button weed voraciously and they had
this normal kind of wing
and then the first one the the third one
that we found the one that never ate the
button need
um it was just kind of
behaving strangely as a caterpillar not
really eating
uh and it emerged and it had these kind
of curled or
abnormal wings and we were able to see
that it could not fly normally
so this is some other views of that one
with the abnormal wings it's it's body
and torso and legs all appeared to be
normal but it's wings again they were
kind of crinkled they weren't spread out
and straight the way the other two
healthy moths were
and so this is what i mean by abnormal
behavior
in this video
you can see that it is
rather than eating it kept kind of
folding over on itself
and moving its mouth along its own body
honestly it kind of looked like a like a
grooming behavior except i'm not aware
of these
caterpillars engaging in any grooming
behavior but it just kept doing this you
know it was kind of folded over
um and and just not interested in eating
at all
and then this was the one that
eventually had those abnormal wings and
so i don't know if the behavior
can you know if that's related to the
abnormal wing development but maybe and
i'd love to know more so if you know
more about these guys and you know what
that behavior was and if it's related to
the
to the winged malformation i would love
to hear it
and this is actually a video that we
took when we released them we released
them just in our front yard and you'll
be able to see two of them that can fly
away and that last one that could not
and so here you know i had originally
taken off the cellophane and they just
wouldn't leave i guess they were
too too used to thinking they couldn't
get out and so i was having to tap on
the bottom there you see it fly away
i was having to tap on the bottom
[Music]
of the of the oxo container to get them
to fly out here i'm doing it to get that
second one to fly out as well
uh
and
eventually it's gonna go realize that
there's no more cellophane at the top
keeping it in and there it went
and now we've got this one that's left
and just you know i kept trying i kept
trying
and it really it could not fly with
those curled deformed wings
and you know we were
trying to decide what to do with it
and you know i considered reaching in
and trying to pull on the on the paper
towel that it was on but i didn't want
to risk damaging it further
so eventually
we did manage to get it out i think i'm
going to skip ahead in the video a
little bit
i set it down i was just hoping it would
go out it couldn't really i laid the oxo
container on its side
and then
finally
see i gave it a little tap again just
trying to get it to leave
the terrarium
we're almost there
oh there it went so you see now it's
kind of under that drain pipe it it
could kind of move around on the ground
it could propel itself but it could not
fly the way the other
the other two could
and so that was our uh
sort of family
project of looking at metamorphosis in
terces inksmocks i hope you enjoyed this
please let me know if you've raised
similar moths or
if you have any questions and thanks for
watching biology professor